we're averaging between five and ten  positive uh  employees on a daily basis um  if you look at our total numbers since  the beginning of march we're right  around 460  positive employees so with my total  workforce  if you did you did the math on that it's  around seven percent positive  um compared to the workforce uh so the  the benchmark for the  state and the county is eight percent so  we're below that benchmark  and which is important to to evaluate  because  we have a little more interaction with  the general public than most people do  and so it's not like we can work from  home  in that vein so i think we're doing a  pretty good job  addressing it on a daily basis basis but  we have concerns in the back of my mind  personally that those numbers are going  to continue to increase